[Musique]
c'est tout je vous en prie prenez pas
mes enfants ouvrent les yeux ouvre les
yeux frais ouvre les yeux
comment vous vous sentez vous dormez un
peu mieux ou bof
j'avais déjà du mal à dormir avant
d'être dans cet état dans cet état vous
êtes enceinte c'est pas un gros mot
savez
[Musique]
je cours c'est un truc tu veux bien
démarré et avec quoi dix mois
[Applaudissements]
rentré à l'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe
les gens disent qu'ils ont vu des
créatures qui peuvent prendre la forme
de ce qu'on redoute le plus c'est vrai
quoi qu'est ce que t'as vu qu'est-ce qui
manque de bazar
pouvait pas rester à chaque fois qu'on
entre en contact avec l'extérieur
s'il vient des morts à chaque fois des
enfants ils ont besoin d'une lueur
d'espoir intérêt toujours passer avant
le reste c'est parti accrochez vous
écoutez moi
on va devoir partir maintenant et ça va
être dur
accrocheurs
vous entendez quelque chose dans la
forêt comme le dit
si vous entendez quelque chose dans
l'eau vous me dites
mais en aucun cas vous n'avez le droit
d'enlever les pentes au de fossiles
[Applaudissements]